what's going on guys this is Rob and you
guys were asking me to cover the new
Marvel Zombies that's what we're going
to cover here now this is a little bit
different than the Marvel zombies that
you're used to and honestly I think it's
better because this is actually three
stories combined into one so what this
does is it initially picks up with
Daredevil and while we don't know
exactly how the zombie outbreak started
things aren't necessarily it's not like
an end of the world type story Instead
at least this part is done in the form
of like kind of fighting ring where
basically people or zombies are fed to
like Daredevil and Daredevil like
attacks the other zombies and basically
takes these other zombies out and people
bet on it and that kind of a thing it's
sort of cool right but it's a little bit
different because they kind of Torment
him a little bit and then kind of stick
him back into a hole and so it's one of
these things where Humanity has just
kind of found a way to use zombies even
for their own personal benefit and of
course Once Matt Murdoch is thrown back
into the hole these just like pieces are
thrown in there for him to essentially
Feast on but here's where things get a
little bit different so in the
traditional Marvel Zombies Mythos
assuming we leave out the most recent
version they did which was absolutely
awful but you look at like the old
Robert Kirkman Marvel Zombies from back
in the day they were zombies but they
were still themselves the difference is
that they just really wanted to eat
flesh right so Spider-Man was very much
like the Peter Parker that you know
except he was using his veins as well
which was really gross and he was still
kind of cracking jokes with this it's
really more grounded and it's a little
more visceral in the sense that with
Matt Murdoch as a zombie he kind of
recollects on his own past so he still
seems to kind of have an idea who he is
even if it's only some kind of distant
memory on a far Shore but it's like
these quotes that kind of come back
right oh my God thank you they were
going to kill me do I don't know what to
me if you hadn't I can't believe this I
mean they would have sued us out of
existence so it's one of those things
where he kind of recollects on the
positive impact that he had on the lives
of people and you kind of get this thing
where as he's consuming this stuff he
just kind of looks down in what seems
like a moment of sadness is very much to
interpretation right now this story with
Matt Murdoch is actually written by G
inis and G inis is really really really
really good when it comes to capturing
like the essence of a character in a
really sad moment the other part of this
is of course no Garth in his story would
be complete without like The Punisher
and the reason for this is because even
when you have Matt Murdoch kind of
recollecting on his own past he also
thinks about like the horrible things
he's done as a zombie the Terrible
Things he's done to other people attack
them kill them different things along
those lines and so what you end up
getting is that while you have these
kind of guards or henchman or whatever
who are the ones that are like sticking
him in the hole this guy kind of comes
out of nowhere right and he says it's
Frank Castle do you remember me and he
says I heard they had you here I can
finish it for you now if you like or I
can turn you into a walking bomb and
tomorrow you can take those animals with
you understand and so this is a really
really cool element because one of the
things to know is that gu inis this guy
has Punisher on lockdown and he has ever
since like the old Punisher stories from
Max Right Up Is Down black is white the
slavers oh my God the slavers was
amazing when he set the guy on fire in
front of the camera and then looked into
it and said don't come back like just
those crazy moments from from Punisher
MAX it was mindblowing some of the stuff
that happened but Punisher is still
going to be Punisher regardless of the
circumstance his war against anybody who
takes life or commits crimes above a
certain threshold they got to go so
Punisher is always going to do that and
that's why he looks at these guys who in
a lot of ways are kind of Abus using
Daredevil if we're really going to put a
word to it and he's just kind of like
we're going to take these guys out but
instead of me being the one to do it I
can kind of help you get the Revenge
that you're looking for right because
even though you're a zombie you're still
in there somewhere and so what he does
at least what Frank Castle does is he
takes out the two guards that have
previously brought him down and then
these other guards end up coming in to
basically grab Matt Murdoch and then
take him up to where he's supposed to be
and that while he's there you end up
finding out that Frank Castle has
literally filled him with explosives he
was literal when he said I will turn you
into a bomb and detonate you that's
exactly what happens because dared devil
lets out this kind of scream that's the
signal to Frank Castle who basically
activates the bombs with inside
Daredevil blows them up and kills
everybody in there and like that's the
end of the Daredevil story it's dope
it's really really really cool so it's
like a lot of little mini stories that
kind of come together to sort of tell
this almost Anthology series about like
Marvel Zombies just depicting them
differently and so the next one switches
over to Spider-Man and this one is
actually probably one of the best Marvel
Spider-Man zombie stories that I think
I've ever read Because what we get is
this really just amazing monologue with
his character there's not a whole lot of
dialogue between himself and anybody
else it all takes place within the span
of about 5 to 10 minutes if that right
it's just a very very confined situation
and he says I don't believe in no- win
scenarios it's the New Yorker in me
learned it from my Aunt May don't give
up she'd always say there's always hope
I felt this in the darkest bleakest
situations I've battled power mad
demigods maniacal Goblins the Devil
Himself but even in the face of
unspeakable odds hope remained because
if we don't have hope what's left and so
in this scenario where zombie outbreaks
kind of just exploded onto the scene
Spider-Man is basically trying to hold
them off off as best he can so that like
J Jonah Jameson and those guys can
essentially escape and J Jonah Jameson
isn't really chastising Spider-Man at
all right he's not really giving him a
hard time right it's just one of these
things where it's kind of like these
statements that are coming in right this
city is completely overrun by these
monsters pandemonium is the word and I
shudder to think it's just these small
little tidbits right these small little
radio blips that are kind of coming in
and so on and so forth right but even
through all of that Spider-Man says even
with my mask on the stinch of death is
overpowering I keep waiting for it for
that glimmer of hope instead I see more
of them they just keep coming now this
is one of the reasons why I love this so
much is because instead of it feeling
like the traditional Robert Kirkman
Marvel zombie stories which this is
going to sound like a very ironic
statement considering that Robert
Kirkman was the one who wrote it it
feels like The Walking Dead meets Marvel
Zombies especially the Spider-Man story
if any of you guys ever read like the
original Walking Dead by Robert Kirkman
it was very similar to this both in
terms of artistic style as well as like
how the characters were written and in
fact there was no color in those old
stories they were just 100% black and
white the way that they were done but in
the midst of all this Spider-Man has
this instinct to like leave right to run
and it's one of those things where he
just kind of stays behind right even J
Jonah Jameson's panicked voice sends a
chill right through Spider-Man because
Jameson's never the guy to panic right
he's never the guy to like freak out and
start losing his mind if anything his
fear gets replaced with anger and so he
just kind of becomes angry and starts
lashing out and he says I'm spent
running on Instinct but I'm their only
chance I think about Aunt May about Mary
Jane I pray they're okay that they've
somehow gotten to safety and that's when
he realizes one of the zombies is
running towards him is Betty Brandt now
for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with Betty Brandt and in fact
it's explained really really well here
Betty brand both worked at the Daily
Planet but more significant than that
she was the first real love interest of
Peter Parker in Marvel Comics before
Gwen Stacy before Mary Jane Watson there
was Betty Branch she was the old school
girlfriend and while the two of them
ended up going their separate ways they
became incredibly good friends in Marvel
to the point that there were even
instances where there were things going
on with Peter Parker that he would
confide in Betty Brandt and he wouldn't
talk to Gwen Stacy or Mary Jane Watson
about those things because seemingly
only she would really understand their
relationship transcended any kind of
Roman involvement and had become
something much much more and so in the
face of all this he realizes it's not
Betty brand though right it was Betty
Brandt once upon a time but it's not her
anymore and he overcomes this desire to
keep himself from attacking her by
literally taking her out but in the
midst of all of that he's radioing in to
the Avengers right to Captain America to
Iron Man to anybody out there but all
he's getting is just kind of a buzzing
sound there's no one there as far as
he's concerned when it comes to the
superhero Community he's an Elmo the
last man on Earth and so it's kind of
nuts because once he starts to realize
what's going on or at least seemingly
there is no help coming hope kind of
begins to fade a little bit but as J
Jonah Jameson and his guys are kind of
making their way out then it's just sort
of like okay I'll hold them off a little
bit longer and then I'll join you only
for him to be met with Aunt May that
Aunt May had turned into a zombie and
Aunt May is about to attack him and
that's the crazy thing here is because
what she says is like where is he
where's Peter Parker what have you done
with my nephew because seemingly Aunt
May doesn't know that Peter's Spider-Man
and so it's a really cool element here
and it kind of feeds into this idea that
yes they're zombies but they're also
still kind of the people that we know
and in fact she even says like what have
you done right like I always knew you
were dangerous that you'd hurt my nephew
he's such a frail nice boy and so she's
attacking him in every sense of the word
right and even gets like abided on it
and so once he initially goes to try to
attack her he realizes he can't it's his
Aunt May right it's like the one person
that he has left in the world that's
like a parental figure for him and in
fact she might as well be his mom
despite the fact that she was his aunt
it's not as easy to just attack her and
take her out and this is cool because it
moves Spider-Man away from just being
like the guy with the mask and like the
sense the spider sense that lets him
like Dodge attacks and swinging around
and is the focal point of two of the
greatest video games ever made in the
history of humanity instead he's just a
guy he's a human and who Among Us would
be able to so easily kill our loved ones
in a moment of panic if some kind of
zombie apocalypse happens we would be in
this exact same situation right we would
Panic we would be scared we'd be torn
right we'd be emotionally caught up in
the situation and so what he ends up
doing is removing his mask and showing
his identity to Aunt May and Aunt May is
is like oh my God I can't believe this
you what have I become she becomes Lucid
right she goes back to her normal self
and she's like please take me out end my
suffering here and Peter does he ends
the suffering of Aunt May here's the
kicker to all of this is that J Jonah
Jameson and all those guys are watching
all of this unfold and even when J Jonah
Jameson realizes it's Peter Parker and
he realizes Peter had to take out his
Aunt May and so on there's a very human
connection that comes from Jameson where
he reaches out to Peter and he says come
on web Menace get in here you don't need
to pretend to be a hero anymore the
response of Spider-Man Jonah please run
for your life because Spider-Man just
turned into a zombie now that's the end
of the Spider-Man
comic that's the end of the Spider-Man
one and so what this does is it switches
to about almost one year after the
zombie outbreak happened and even though
it wasn't actually drawn by him this one
with moonight looks like it was drawn by
Liam sharp and the reason why I say that
is because Liam sharp just has a really
really difficult to appreciate art style
it's all just an amalgamation and an
amorphous blob of like characters and
surroundings just combined into a comic
book panel it makes it a hassle but this
whole thing with moonight is actually
dealing with both him and the moon God
konu now moonight says the last of the
survivors should reach Zone C by
mourning the response of konu good we
can then be done with this city so what
seems like has happened here between the
initial outbreak that took place and
this moment here Humanity has set up
safe zones Humanity set up safe spots in
different places both around the city of
New York and most likely even the rest
of the country and the world again it's
one of the cool elements about this
story is we don't know how far reaching
it is and we don't know how much of
society has collapsed but the response
of moonight is we have to help these
people K you and con's response is we
have to help all travelers of the night
we've stayed too long now that's one of
the important things here and that's
where the relationship between the two
seems relatively interesting because
nine times out of 10 K's involvement
when it comes to Mark Spectre is usually
one of manipulation it's one of getting
him to do K shu's own bidding and not
really caring about the nature of Mark
Spector and in fact if I remember
correctly during Jeff Lam's moonnight
run probably one of the greatest runs of
all time
we actually ended up learning the
motivation behind konu and choosing an
avatar on Earth is to basically drive
that person insane destroy their
identity quote unquote Hollow them out
so that konu himself can take over their
body and then function on Earth so he
never really had any actual love for
Mark Spectre him being an avatar for
konu was just a means to an end so the
two never quite saw eye to eye but
what's interesting here is konu appears
more like a mentor than anything else
right like when konu says that we've
stayed too long moonight responds in
saying and I say we haven't stayed long
enough and where konu responds and
asking you still do not trust me
moonight says of course I don't when
have you ever had my best interest in
mind and he says no you promised you
would help me fix this and that's when
konu says we are not alone now seemingly
there was nothing that konu could do and
the reason why I say that is one of the
things to understand when it comes to
konu is that within the Godly pan on the
kind of hierarchy that exists out there
konu is an Earthly God a new God if you
could call him that he's by no means on
par with a cosmic entity he's more in
line with maybe kind of Odin at least if
only in like a ceremonial role certainly
not on the same level of power right
he's more comparable to like the panther
goddess Bast or something along those
lines what's seemingly Happening Here is
well beyond K's ability to basically fix
Galactus probably could right which
would make a really interesting scenario
I mean technically Galactus didn't do
anything to stop in the original Marvel
zombies and in fact he got consumed but
presumably Galactus could do something
about it right manipulating the power
Cosmic and being able to create life
destroy life y ya y he could just wipe
out the whole of the earth and then
restore it and make things back to the
way they were before and like that would
basically be it but what's going on here
is that while they are not alone the
reason for that is because Iron Man
shows up here and Iron Man immediately
starts going after moonight but you end
up finding out that Iron Man is the
Avatar of Anubis on Earth that while
Anubis is not seemingly the source of
the zombie outbreak or if he is he
doesn't really say it explicitly on the
nose he is using it as a kind of excuse
right a chance to make his move and to
take over Earth and so the fight between
moonight and Iron Man is pretty intense
and in fact Anubis even says this virus
is a gift you will see that consu but
first I needed a way to prevent you and
your vessel from interfering fortunately
I found an undead host more than willing
of course that person being Iron Man and
of course konu says in this now Mark and
the two of them kind of start going back
and forth now of course moonight kind of
gets the upper hand on Iron Man to a
degree right like slashing at him with
one of his Moon daggers or you know Moon
rangs whatever you want to call it and
then in turn Iron Man's kind of like hey
Anubis they don't need all their limbs
to be zombies right as long the virus
spreads I get a free pass to do anything
I want and so in turn he says
unfortunately for you and then he rips
somebody's arm off and it's kind of hard
to tell who he is it's hard to tell if
it's like a nubis right it's not
moonight because like moonight has his
arms right like his arms are there he's
just kind of laying there with his arm
attached to his body right so I don't
really know whose arm got ripped off but
what's kind of nuts here is the response
of konu is get up Mark right and that's
when Mark says the virus is spreading I
can't think straight I'm going to die
they're going to die right Mark Spectre
is succumbing to the very virus that's
been infecting everybody and then K and
turn replies when have you ever needed
your mind my son faith has never needed
rationality trust in my guidance and
that's when like this random guy out
there is just kind of like please don't
kill me and the response of Iron Man is
and who's going to stop me right
moonight jumps in attacks Iron Man and
then just beats this guy to death right
like just absolutely crushes him and
that's when consu is like my son my
vessel you've listened well you must be
hungry do not worry who am I to deny my
avatar and in fact this innocent guy in
an alley is fed to Mark Spectre by konu
and kuu in turn says we will soon run
out of your former allies to consume but
I can indulge you for now I am a
merciful father but you must listen to
me can you do that my son I will soon
rebuild you in my image but for now
finish this so in effect now moonight is
K's avatar on Earth in a zombie form
attacking all the zombified superheroes
that exist out there in the world but
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end right it's only the
first issue there's going to be more
that come out of this but it's really
really cool let me know what you guys
think about this down in the comments
section I'm really curious but I will
catch you all later
peace